hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on for honor again and
with the trailer of the newest hero out
now called hold o or better known us or
possible in game name your Meg Andrew
let's delve deep into the lore of this
character and figure out who she really
is and what we can uncover about it and
went to help us and meet you guys in the
comments section and Google we can find
some answers and some theories about
Yurman Gander so call me mr. ginger your
history teacher in high school and let's
delve in deep and what we can find out
about your main Gander first up we have
to define a few words that will be used
frequently throughout this video such as
Ragnarok and Jorma Gander Yurman Gander
is from north mythology meaning sea
serpent this sea serpent lived in the
ocean that surrounds Midgard Yurman
Gander makes many appearances throughout
media and modern times such as the game
smite and God of War and even has an own
anime called Gorman gained Herman Gander
is so big that he can wrap his body
around the world of Midgard like an
Ouroboros Midgard is one of the nine
worlds in Norse mythology these worlds
and having multiple things for example
the world of Alpha has the home of light
elves and the and the home of Jotunheim
is the home of giants Midgard is the
home of humans aka Earth and in terms of
more lurid yarman ganders arch-enemy is
the god of thunder and lightning himself
thor and it's also assumed that the sea
serpents father is also Loki who ended
up also having a couple other creations
such as hell and Fenrir with him Thor
wanted to kill your man Gander himself
one time on a fishing trip so he set out
to sea but before he did that the line
ended up breaking when the giant Amir
struck it he Amir was very worried that
bringing your man Gander to land would
trigger Ragnarok Ragnarok is a series of
events including a giant battle foretold
to lead to the death of many numerous
great figures including gods such as
Odin Thor Loki and many more after these
events would occur the surviving gods
would then meet up and repopulate the
world again with the two human survivors
these are apparently the only two humans
that would survive Ragnarok leaving this
a very deadly battle and having many
casualties God and humans alike
suffering large loss in numbers but
regardless when your mean gander does
arrive Thor is destined by fate to fight
him going off this and more info and it
said that your man gander will arise
from the water and poison the sky while
Fenrir will set the world ablaze and
then they meet in Vig read where Thor
awaits to finally do battle with the
serpent
Hulda in the trailer says we have waited
and devoted ourselves to the great cause
bring your wrath Ragnarok comes with
this and the previous stuff set in mind
it's not too much to assume that Holda
and great art the female and male name
of the new character respectively our
followers are a cultist of the Great Sea
serving your man gander is heavily
supported by the surfing constantly
being shown in the trailer and the
clouds and the fact that the trailer
takes place on some rocks nearby a big
body of water is at least to our luckily
occultist which are people dedicated to
occultism which is a theory or practice
in the belief or study of actions
influenced by supernatural powers so
it's really not too far to assume like
I've said that Hulda and guitar are a
cultists who worship the Great Sea
servant Norman gander let me know what
you guys think obviously I don't think
your man dinners going to be coming out
of the map anytime soon and if the new
map with this fortress does have a
little sneak peek I know and one of the
Viking maps seasons ago there'd be a
little type of animal I think it was
like a dolphin or some whale or
something that would come up out of the
water every so often if we can get
something like that in the breach map
where your main Gander comes up for a
brief second or maybe you can see his
eyes or a shadow in the distance that'd
be really cool and I'd love to see that
in the new breach map and then as for
relating to this character I'm assuming
that the name of course is going to be
your man gander seeing as they are big
occultist of the character your man
gander this great sea serpent so they
most likely will be taking the name with
them into the game and joining the
roster with us and they most likely will
be having some new type of effects that
relate to being some type of sea serpent
or anything like that so if any of that
comes by and you happen to equip that it
would definitely look historically
accurate yeah but let me know what you
guys think about the character down
below first off we've only of course
seen a trailer of the character as the
time I'm making this video but if you
happen to be watching this after
Thursday which is when the reveal of the
new character goes live also let me know
in the comments below what you guys
think of that I'm super excited to see
how this character plays out look at the
new executions and stuff we got to be
seeing some gruesome stuff seeing is
your man gander there's gonna be causing
all this mad series of events like
Ragnarok I would assume that these
executions will be just as powerful and
just as brutal as Ragnarok itself and
know in terms of human form of what you
can do with that yeah guys like I said
let me know in the comments below what
you guys think if I did get something
wrong let me know in the comments below
and I'll be sure to address it in the
Pin comment or
have any more stories or any more lower
things that I happen to miss or maybe I
glossed over and didn't put in the video
also let me know that as well and also
try to add that in a huge pin comment
detailing everything about this
character because honestly in terms of a
lore perspective definitely a big fan of
this character the most I've always been
a big fan of mythology such as Greek in
Norse mythology so this stuff is gonna
be crazy and I cannot wait to play this
character when she releases on August
1st yeah what that like to be if you do
enjoy guys subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational site a foreigner
that being the balance changes the hero
updates the petrous and the leaks so if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner I never miss out on an update
that we say subscribe to the channel if
you did enjoy the lore video definitely
make sure to let me know in the comments
below and leave a like and I'll be doing
one for next season when we get the rule
in hero whatever that one happens to be
but with that my two most recent videos
are gonna be popping up on the screen if
you guys do want to check that out but
that guy's so bitter it's turday thank
you for watching the video and I'll see
you for the reveal stream on Thursday or
I'll see you for the day that the this
season actually goes live peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you